what up everybody this is oven Kyle on
from la zone breakfast sandwich kingdom
egg [ __ ] eggs put me on the map but
burgers bro dads with tugs on my
heartstrings I'm a burger freak I love
burgers right oh yeah [ __ ] good
burger now from classic fast-food
patties smashed on the griddle it's a
high-end versions tricked out in the
kitchen man I love them all
the universe is spoken and burgers are
the reason why I'm in New York City
it's almost like the easy of meat it's
next-level [ __ ] people call you the
burger scholar how many hamburgers have
you actually eaten you things like
12,000 burgers oh my god yo man this is
the most baller burger I've ever even
looked at so I'm too busy picking the
deep with a gold diamond too thick now
I'm on a quest to figure out what drives
my obsession and I'm linking up with
some Burger homies to help me along the
way you have a lot of things that we
like about the Shake Shack burger you
have a lot of things we liked about the
in-and-out burger
let's just put it together and it makes
them in and out Shake Shack babies
you're a madman
let's give a shot
dude the bun changes the game you
thought you like Kim's buns get lower
Martin's I feel like we just broke da
vinci's code unlike what's gonna be the
next level of burger trend
[Music]